so what's our plan
buck i have a plan
oh i have all of that on camera great
exclusively on disney plus
these guys use brute force they're
strong
too strong then they might be a part of
the big three what victory
androids aliens and wizards that's not a
thing that's definitely
no it's not
there are no wizards dr schrein is a
sorcerer a sorcerer is a wizard without
a hat
original series streaming march 19th
exclusively on disney plus
our country is vulnerable
we need new heroes
let's get to work we're not a team
nope or
partners
co-workers
we look damn good
streaming march 19th exclusively on
disney plus
the world's upside down right now
where do we start
superheroes that cannot be allowed
people to exist they need a cat
damn right
original series streaming march 19th
exclusively on disney plus
[Music]
the legacy of that shield is
complicated
[Music]
the world
it's upside down
people need something to get behind
[Music]
i need a symbol
so what's our plan
so no plan
[Music]
great
[Music]
what's going on in that cyborg brain of
yours you don't want to know
oh yeah i can see it working gear's
turning
oh they're malfunctioning they're on
fire
you